many americans rang in the new year with
hopes for a brighter new year and of
course a new round of resolutions tends
to follow well this morning
we're joined by experts with tips to
improve your finances and your physical
and mental health
in the year to come and of course after
a year that was dominated by the
coronavirus many people are reflecting
on the importance of their health and
wellness for 2021
and with vaccines on the way there's at
least one reason to be optimistic
cbs news senior medical correspondent dr
tara narula joins us now
tara good morning to you happy new year
i want to begin
with a kind of perplexing number from
the cdc apparently four in
ten americans delayed or avoided the
doctor
in 2021 what does that mean for doctor
visits in the year to come and what
should we be asking our doctor as we
show up again for maybe the first time
in a year
well good morning and happy new year to
you and you said it tony so many
americans missed those
important medical visits this past year
and so now is a great time to circle
back with your primary care provider i
like to call them the quarterback of the
team
and really have a discussion about what
important tests particularly screening
tests things like
mammograms and colonoscopies you need to
catch up with
also you want to talk about vaccinations
and what you might be behind on and it's
a great time to have a discussion with
your primary
about any questions you have about the
covid vaccine
certainly patients who have any chronic
medical conditions so cardiovascular
disease kidney disease diabetes
you need to be in touch with your
specialists who are managing you to make
sure that you are
on top of those conditions i like to say
that it's also a good time to take a
medication inventory so many people end
up on medications they're not sure why
they're on them they may be interacting
with other drugs they're taking so
have a conversation with your primary
about everything you're on and what you
really need to be on
and finally i'm a cardiologist so i have
to put in a plug for cardiovascular
disease and knowing your numbers and
risk factors it's still the leading
cause
of death of both men and women in this
country well we mentioned resolutions at
the top and i think this is related to
heart health
weight loss that is a very common
resolution
and people have had some struggles in
2020 and myself included because gyms
were closed in many cases for at least
portions of the year
so what do people do in 2021 to get back
on the treadmill so to speak
it's so true and almost every single one
of my patients has told me that they've
really
taken a nose dive when it comes to their
nutrition diet and exercise but just
because gyms are closed doesn't mean
it's an excuse not to be active you can
certainly get outside
whether it's for a run a walk a bike
also you can do
sports that maybe don't require close
contact things like tennis
there's so many fitness apps you can
stream classes
youtube has dance classes you can do so
there are definitely ways to stay active
in your home and you want to make it if
you can if you have kids too a family
activity a lot of our kids are in front
of screens
all day you want to make sure that
they're getting the recommended 60
minutes of exercise aerobic exercise
daily
and for adults for cardiovascular health
it's about 150 minutes of aerobic
exercise per week that you want to focus
on that's a good reminder i'm not sure i
was getting that but i was greatly
relieved that i was able to put on this
tux with only limited strain
before this conversation so good on me
one final question i checked the tape
and last year
your new year's resolution was increased
mindfulness
one year later how did you do
we did pretty good we i say because it
became a whole family
resolution i downloaded an app called
calm which i
love and i now recommend to all my
patients and i learned how to meditate
there's really easy ways to do it you
can do it at your desk in the office at
home at night so now my husband's doing
it
we taught our kids how to do it so we've
stayed on top of it and it's really been
a nice
form of centering and grounding during a
time that's been
so stressful for everyone bravo dr
narula thank you very much and gail
there you have it most new year's
resolutions
are given up after about two weeks but
doctor naruto made it the whole year and
she had a good one too mindfulness
bravo dr tara narula and i can also
suggest head space
calm is good but so is head space you've
got some options out there